[Music]
on this friday night
a devastating discovery in bc
a graveyard full of hundreds of children
at a former residential school
they're as little as you know like
potentially like three years old
the investigation underway a convicted
sex offender involved with a youth
basketball camp
for decades he made it clear that he
wanted
sexual favors a global news exclusive
new calls to loosen rules for
international travelers why
some experts feel it's time to check out
a hotel quarantine
from getting a shot to hitting the
jackpot i still can't believe it
the first winners of some major pandemic
prizes
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight with the horrific
discovery of a suspected
burial site for children some as young
as three
at the former kamloops indian
residential school in british columbia
the remains of what's believed to be 215
children
were found in unmarked graves thousands
of indigenous children died of abuse and
neglect
after being forced to attend residential
schools across canada
today a moment of silence was held in
the house of commons
prime minister justin trudeau says the
discovery is heartbreaking tweeting
today
it is a painful reminder of that dark
and shameful chapter in
our country's history the national chief
of the assembly of first nations perry
belgaard
also tweeted saying it's always crushing
to have that chapter's wounds
exposed paul johnson is in kamloops
where an investigation
is now underway paul farah there's a
portion of their property near the banks
of the south thompson river that they've
got
closed off that's where the suspected
mass grave site is
if this turns out to be what they think
it is
this is going to be a staggering and
heartbreaking moment in canadian history
the kamloops residential school was run
by the catholic church
it operated from 1890 until 1977.
among the first nations children from
across bc's interior
who were forcibly brought here there
were rumors of deaths
and burials in unmarked graves now
the tekemloops first nation says they've
found proof
we do know that they've had
members who shared the stories of you
know
cousins and relations and siblings who
have been missing
and you know the common theme that
they've all
heard was that that their sibling their
sister their brother their consultant
had run away
with that find you know we do know that
we know that these children did not run
away to kamloops chief roseanne casimir
says a search of the school
property with ground penetrating radar
has revealed the presence
of at least 215 bodies
from the imagery obtained they suspect
many are small children
it was very horrifying to learn that
we've had
found 215 you know remains of children
you know within our grounds we were
going through grief and loss here
knowing that these were children who
were the children
how did they die what were their stories
all of that
is unknown at this point but the
stunning news has already touched
the greater kamloops first nation
community
many of whom gathered at a site near the
school friday
to share their grief
this is a piece of history
that is a devastating injustice to
to our people gerald etienne was a
student at the school for five years
he also heard the chilling rumors there
is a story of another grave site beside
the gym over here in that parking lot
there's supposed to be
there were stories of grave sites there
i don't know how many but
you know those kind of things were told
and came to my ears
now they wait for confirmation uncertain
how they'll face it
and how all of canada will the chief is
telling us they plan to have an initial
report out here in a matter of just a
few weeks in the meantime
they're in the process of reaching out
to the rcmp
and the bc coroner's service farah
paul johnson in kamloops british
columbia thank you paul
a global news investigation has revealed
some unsettling information
involving a youth basketball school in
saskatchewan
over the span of a year it examined how
convicted sex offender dennis hull
was involved in the young athlete
saskatchewan program for decades
even after he was sentenced as nathaniel
dove explains in this exclusive report
it's now raising new questions around
child safety
at sports camps kind of got
awkwardly close to me and said like of
course
if you and your girlfriends move in here
like
like cleaning wouldn't be the only thing
i would get you to do to repay me
sylvia was 18 and working at her boss's
home office in 2002
when she says he propositioned her
global news agreed not to use her real
name
he made it clear that he wanted sexual
favors and for
for payment for rent to stay there rent
free
sylvia eventually reported him to police
who said there was nothing that would
lead to an
investigation or charges she told global
news she met the man
at a basketball camp in saskatoon dennis
robert hall
appears to have been involved with it
since 1983. in 1981
a judge convicted hall for two counts of
having sex with girls
between the ages of 14 and 16 and two
counts of indecent assault against two
other adolescent girls
according to news coverage at the time
all four played for a church basketball
team which he started coaching in the
1970s
global news spoke to one of the
survivors it started off very you know
innocently you know hugging you and then
you know you're upset and you're crying
and you know and then
you know giving you a kiss on the
forehead like your father would
multiple media outlets have previously
reported hall received a pardon in 1994.
in saskatchewan there are no regulations
prohibiting
anyone convicted of committing sexual
offenses against minors
from being involved with a private
sports camp an email from a camp account
to a parent stated hall hasn't been
involved in years
no one from the camp responded to
global's inquiries but photos on the
website from 2011 to last year
appear to show hall was there global
news contacted hall several times for
this story
even questioning him in person you ever
offered
your place to stay for a worker if they
stay the night with you
he did not respond to any requests for
comment
in a statement the saskatchewan
government said it has not been made
aware of issues that would require
provincial regulation of sports camps
the federal government said abuse has no
place in sports
that it's working to implement a
universal code of conduct
but provincial bodies regulate summer
camps a legal expert says some
governments and organizations have
improved how they protect children over
the past 40 years
but monique saint-germain says children
are still not safe
it would be nice to see national
standards across the board
for things like the protection of
children nathaniel dove global news
saskatoon in part two of our special
investigation
global news obtains a police report
detailing allegations
against the man involved with that
sports camp how police handled the case
tomorrow
on global national now to the covet 19
pandemic
new federal modeling shows much of the
country is making steady progress
in controlling the third wave yet dr
teresa tam is warning
many more canadians must be vaccinated
to safely ease restrictions
our efforts have got us well and truly
over the peak of the third wave
nationally
and heading for a much better summer if
we can stay the course
now is not the time to relax our
measures
tam says at least 75 percent of
canadians 12 and older need their first
dose
and 20 percent need their second to
safely begin easing restrictions
federal numbers show there is progress
in all age groups but
there is still a ways to go as of
tonight 54
of canadians have had at least one dose
and 4.8 percent
have been fully vaccinated ontario's
become the latest province to speed up
appointments for
second doses the province says people 80
and up can start booking their second
shots next week
depending on supply the weight for some
people may be much less than 16 weeks
everyone in ontario who wants a vaccine
could be fully vaccinated by the end of
august
that's right friends ontario is ready to
deliver a two dose summer
and with vaccination rates climbing
calls are growing to loosen rules
on travel a new report by a group of
canadian experts says
fully vaccinated travelers who test
negative should not have to quarantine
it also recommends scrapping the
mandatory hotel quarantine for air
travelers
abigail beeman explains why and how the
government
is responding i don't travel for
holidays
i don't travel for vacation i travel
because i need
to work and provide for my family as a
pro tennis official working around the
globe
damiano torrella is not exempt from
quarantine
when he comes home the cost of a
quarantine hotel means he needs to
choose between not working
or a lengthy time away from his wife and
young children
he welcomes the new report calling on
the government to scrap the hotel
program
citing a variety of problems i think it
would be finally
something based on common sense and
science
and not just politics we do not have
evidence that that shows that we have
actually reduced the transmission
of the virus through the quarantine
hotels and
and remember the the quarantine period
for those hotels is only three days
which is inconsistent with the science
around the the
incubation period the advisory panel
also suggests
looser quarantine rules overall instead
of two weeks
for people who aren't vaccinated it
recommends a test on day seven
and an end to quarantine whenever a
negative result comes back
people with one dose would only need to
quarantine until a test
taken on arrival day comes back negative
and for those
fully vaccinated the panel recommends no
quarantine
unless a test taken at arrival comes
back positive
it's quite a complex space and needs a
thoughtful consideration
the move is welcomed by airline and
travel industries and canadians like
melinda schneider separated from her
boyfriend in denmark while both attend
school i understood being very very very
restrictive and very protected
when they didn't know how to treat it
when there was no preventative anything
when there
but we know so much more now but the
premier of the country's biggest
province again called on the prime
minister for
more border protections this could cause
a fourth wave
if we don't tighten up the borders
friday the u.k
prime minister confirmed justin trudeau
plans to attend the next g7 summit
in person it's in two weeks it would be
trudeau's first foreign trip since
before the pandemic
and there's no word yet as to whether
the canadian government plans to drop
the quarantine requirement
before he returns abigail beeman global
news
ottawa the canadian armed forces has
deployed resources to manitoba to help
the province through its brutal
third wave a specially equipped hercules
aircraft is now in winnipeg to help
transport critically ill covid19
patients out of province for care
according to the military the aircraft
can carry two patients at a time
as of tonight 27 manitobans are being
treated out of province
one is in saskatchewan and the rest are
in ontario
nova scotia is emerging from its biggest
coveted 19 surge with
its reopening plan restrictions will
ease in five phases
starting next week based on data not
dates
we can move through the phases hopefully
every two to four weeks
if we're hitting our vaccine targets and
our epi is fine we should be able to
move through things in in two week
phases
and some of canada's top athletes got
their second dose today
members of the canadian olympic and
paralympic teams were able to get their
second
pfizer shot at a special clinic in
toronto the canadian olympic committee
is aiming to get everyone fully
vaccinated ahead
of the tokyo games in july
it's nice to leave to know that you know
kind of doing our part um
especially japan happens and we're going
that we're
not putting them at risk when we head
over and we have a bit of extra safety
as well
if japan's olympics will happen is what
many people are wondering
the country is extending its state of
emergency in tokyo and other areas for
20 more days
because infection rates are still not
slowing down
today the president of the tokyo olympic
organizing committee
hinted even local fans may be barred
from venues
when the games do open on july 23rd
it's the mission to reduce carbon
emissions coming up how big oil is
undergoing a big
change to be more eco-friendly
a significant shift is underway in the
oil and gas sector
after more than seven decades the
canadian association of oil well
drilling contractors
has changed its name it's now known as
the canadian association of energy
contractors
the new name comes with a new mandate
developing
greener energy around the world
companies are being forced to revamp to
address the global climate crisis
as eric sorenson reports the energy
evolution
is beginning to look like a revolution
[Applause]
in the netherlands climate advocates
celebrate after oil giant royal dutch
shell was ordered to cut
carbon emissions almost in half by 2030.
shell is appealing but the decision by a
dutch court could pave the way for
similar cases worldwide
this is a groundbreaking verdict as far
as i'm concerned
royal.shell is ordered by the court to
do its share in
avoiding dangerous climate change a
growing surge in climate awareness
saw several head spinning changes at
major oil companies this week
exxon lost two seats on its board to
activist investors who want the company
to do more to address global warming and
a shareholder rebellion at chevron voted
to force that company
to cut its carbon emissions pressure to
change is coming from both outside and
inside big oil there are people that
really want to see this fundamental
change
and it's you know getting right into the
boardroom and that means that
we're going to start to see these
companies responding and making some of
these tough decisions
in canada there are growing challenges
attracting investments in the western
oil patch
one academic says companies more than
governments see the need to become more
nimble it's no surprise to them
but it's a surprise to our political
leaders in alberta and saskatchewan
they have placed all their bets
on the fossil fuel industry but
governments too could see their hands
forced
the court is satisfied that a duty of
care should be recognized
an australian court judgment from a
lawsuit brought by a group of teenagers
ruled the government has a duty to
protect future generations from climate
change
in this case when it comes to expanding
coal production this case was about
young people stepping up and demanding
more from the adults whose actions are
determining our future well-being
more evidence friday that big oil
companies get it
french oil and gas giant total announced
a rebranded image
the future will see total become a
multi-energy enterprise what the ceo
calls
a green energy company in the majority
grassroots climate advocates say genuine
change will come
not just when oil companies diversify
but when they stop
investing in new oil and gas projects
eric sorensen global news
toronto the oil and gas sector is at a
crossroads still ahead
the path to decarbonization here
as countries work to decarbonize canada
has been slowed
by an economy deeply grounded in oil and
gas
yet this country is quietly becoming a
leader in technology
they could be indispensable in bridging
that gap
i spoke with derek evans he's the
president and ceo of meg energy
a leading oil company that's setting an
ambitious goal of net zero
based on the prospect of carbon
the oil and gas sector is at a
crossroads and for derrick evans the way
out
is through decarbonization so
to me it's a natural step in the
evolution of the oil and gas business
like canada itself meg energy aims to
achieve net zero emissions by 2050.
for evans the only realistic path
includes carbon capture
it's the single biggest lever that we
have to pull to
actually start to decarbonize this is a
technology that exists today
this is one that we could put in the
field in one sense carbon capture is the
most direct solution to the emissions
problem
simply return the carbon to the earth as
fossil fuels are burned instead of being
released into the air the co2 is
chemically isolated and captured
then compressed and sent via pipeline to
a location to be stored underground
globally there are more than two dozen
such facilities
but canada is home to some of the
largest and most advanced
including the boundary dam in
saskatchewan the quest facility near
edmonton
and the alberta carbon trunk line and
it's near christina lake alberta
where meg energy hopes to erase most of
its own emissions
the biggest barrier for evidence the
endless political fighting over the
carbon tax
a clear price on admissions that
incentivizes future planning
for anybody to undertake a carbon
capture and storage project
they're going to want to know that there
is going to be a
contractually set price of carbon that
they can take to the bank
and say look we want to build this
project that sort of uncertainty
has been a big big problem for
people in the business that wanted to
move forward on carbon capture and
storage
and while critics point to its high cost
in long time lines
the federal budget introduced a
corporate tax credit for carbon capture
it's just a fraction of the 30 billion
dollars in funding
that alberta is asking ottawa for in the
coming years
do you think that there's a real shift
when it comes to the oil and gas sector
in alberta
oh there's a there's a a palpable shift
the
urgency to get after doing more
on the carbon file has definitely
increased
you're seeing um large portions of the
oil and gas sector saying
this is something we need to turn our
attention to
and we need to agitate and get in front
of government and say this is
how we can um achieve your
your paris accord goals was there
something specific that changed your
view
on this i'd say the specific piece was
frustration
um it was frustration that we have
continued to talk and talk
and talk about this and our children are
going to hang us up by the thumbs
uh for our lack of action on on this
file we need to chart that path forward
and we need to
chart it in an aggressive fashion carbon
capture is no magic bullet
but in a long road to net zero it's
becoming harder to see a way forward
without it
million dollar immunity next the 22 year
old who got vaccinated
and got rich
imagine if you could win a million
dollars just for getting your covid 19
shot well that's the big prize the state
of ohio offered people
as an incentive to get vaccinated this
was abigail buginski's reaction when the
governor told her
she was the state's first lucky winner
completely surprised when i got the call
and i'm i still can't believe it i'm
definitely not quitting my job
the 22 year old is a mechanical engineer
working on her master's degree and
although she's very excited she's trying
to stay grounded
planning to use summer for weddings to
buy a used car
invest and as she mentioned keep her job
i know what schools i would some schools
i might want to go to
like miami university
and that's joseph costello he's talking
about his college goals
the 14 year old won a four-year
scholarship as part of the lottery
four more drawings will be held in the
coming weeks
and as a side note joseph's mom said she
was always going to give her kids the
vaccine but
the lottery there the scholarship
lottery certainly accelerated the
timeline
that's global national for this friday
night i'm fary nasser tonight's your
canada is the national art gallery in
ottawa
during this month's tulip festival we
love seeing your canada so please keep
sending us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us robin gill is going
to be with you tomorrow
until friday take care of yourselves and
each other